i've been mad at you i'm sorry for
hurting you
eight girls in want moms just found out
that colt
has been sending nudes to other women
at this point the only thing i could do
is come clean and be honest with her and
tell her the truth about everything
that's happened
there's something else i need to come
clean about
and that something else is going to be
the tipping point
that brings jess to tears this is too
much for me
because i always love it of course oh
just hey 90 day fans fam it's melissa
on the latest episode of happily ever
after what was done in the dark
came to the light
[Music]
you went to immigration what yep
and while karini told paul the truth it
seems like
colt he's still struggling in the
honesty department
look you lie all the time you just see
you
believe in your life just you because
you repeat you say you
you forget you lied before cool do you
have a problem you need a doctor
yeah she went there look after watching
this episode
i am convinced i'm convinced that colt
either makes decisions for a storyline
or he just likes to see girls go crazy
over him she's very angry i feel like
she's a little
firecracker that could go off any second
all right
let me go ahead and give you a rundown
of colt and jess's first day together
in vegas from start to end okay
once just landed colt prepared to leave
his house
but before he did he stopped to talk to
a person who is now staying with him
a person who just despises
have you told her about me yet of course
he hasn't vanessa
colt's bright idea is to tell her once
she gets to his house
he also has something else he plans on
telling her
i have to confess that i've been talking
to other women while we were broken up
at the time i thought jess and i were
done i just hope she doesn't break up
with me as soon as she hears it
who knows maybe jess and i can work
things through
and i'm really hoping i just see her and
there's that moment it's like you see
each other and you don't care what
happened between you
or it's just like oh i remember all the
good things
i highly doubt that's gonna happen
right vanessa i appreciate your honesty
well colt left the house and met up with
jess at a cat cafe because
they both love cats but the kitties
didn't distract them from their issues
for
too long little did colt know jess came
to vegas
already aware of these other women
and she had receipts what exactly is
bothering you right now
[Music]
how's your you send pictures today
what are you talking about stop listen
in two weeks you sent for eight girls
i have a screenshot for eight girls
you know send pictures for girls and
videos
good morning my how are you my
goodnights oh i forget my
this is crazy cole didn't have much to
say
after just outed him but he did reveal
to the producers that
he was embarrassed and just started
talking about the other women online
that i
have been talking to and mentioning
pictures i
i don't know i got
mortified honestly while i was talking
to these women online
i sent them pics i'm ashamed of myself
oh colt at this point colt decided to
take jess
back to his house because he didn't want
to get yelled at
at the cat cafe i feel embarrassed by
the whole thing
but she also had her own responsibility
she blocked me
whenever she wanted to she unblocked me
she was on and off again
i i felt like i wasn't even part of a
relationship most of the time
well once they got to colt's house the
conversation continued
he eventually apologized for hurting
jess
but then he dropped this bomb on her
i haven't been a very good boyfriend
there's
something else i need to come clean
about
so vanessa moved in a few weeks ago
what she moved in not very long ago she
needed a place to stay
she's in the third bedroom no
i could feel jess's blood boiling
through the screen what an uncomfortable
and unfair situation to be put in
by someone who says they care about you
i'm not sure if we're gonna see vanessa
and jess
interact at all next week because
honestly
if i was ever in that position which i
highly doubt would ever be the case
i would leave colt's house immediately
but hey jess is jess and not melissa
so what she's gonna do i'm not sure as
of right now
it's all up in the air
[Music]
our final must-see moment goes to carini
who has taken matters into her own hands
she admits that she's desperate she's
not adjusting well in the u.s
she's tired of fighting with paul and
he still hasn't found a job so now she's
decided to meet with an immigration
attorney
to see how she can get home to brazil do
you have your documents with you
like your passport or anything else
you have no comments may i see them oh
okay
carini came prepared and the immigration
attorney revealed that
based off of her status she has the
right
to come and go into the u.s but
the attorney also let her know that this
isn't a cut and dry situation
and there could be negative consequences
it would be wrong just to assume that
this could happen without any resistance
paul has just as many rights as she does
he could show up to the airport and try
to stop everything or attempt to take
charges out
he could try to put her in family court
proceedings
i just don't know what he would do
my advice to you just take your child on
good terms
you have to realize what you're dealing
with is not easy before having a
knee-jerk reaction that will affect your
child's life
take some time carini
took the attorney's advice and when paul
arrived back at the house later on
she told him how she spent her day
and of course he got upset i talked to
the lawyer
did you go to immigration attorney
first of all how did you get there if we
do we'll be sardinia
i ordered uber by myself she said that i
have the right to travel with pierre
alone do what
so you want to take the baby and just
leave just leave me here
is that it i will prosecute
in brazil and america you can't keep the
child from me no combo
this is very real that argument ended
with carini
breaking down in tears and paul
attempting
to console her come here
on next week's episode i guess he tries
to make things right
by taking his wife to a sanitation plant
in the rain what are we doing here
we're gonna see uh it's a poop water
facility just show you
some of the uh things like they have in
america
[Music]
that was offensive paul
all i can think about is pierre's
adorable face
i just really want them to get it
together for him
alright 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t
because we are covering it all i'll see
you next time
you